over 4 000 miles away and on another
continent
but here was a home secretary arriving
to unveil a plan that places rwanda at
the heart of our immigration policy
her proposal to punch a one-way ticket
to east africa for people who reach the
uk illegally an agreement she hopes will
deter people from dangerous journeys
like channel crossings
they'll stay in accommodation like this
block
here the government says they'll have
their asylum claims processed before
taking steps to rebuild their lives
potentially in rwanda
this used to be a hostel but it's
already being prepared for the arrival
of asylum seekers from the uk there are
50 rooms in this block including places
to eat and sleep but essentially it's a
holding center where those people will
wait for their asylum claims to be
processed
pretty patel was confident that building
and this country will be a safe space
australia set up their own offshore
processing system and there are reports
of
self-harming and even people taking
their own lives how will you ensure the
well-being of asylum seekers sent to
rwanda do you see that as a uk
government's responsibility or are you
passing the bloc australia is not
comparable this is not the type of
arrangement that australia had australia
as a sovereign country obviously had its
own arrangement um it is fair to say um
our teams have been working through
facilities here you've heard me mention
in my opening remarks as well the
technical experience that we are
bringing we believe in investing in
rwanda we're very open about that
rwanda's foreign minister feels they are
ready to process thousands we assessed
our capacity to
receive
migrants and we know that we have a
capacity in place to
to receive migrants
to reach that point though they'll need
to scale up fast
here they're planning to build two more
blocks
on top of that politicians don't want to
deal with a british backlog if our kids
rwanda's kid has not the possibility to
go at school because of the poverty
how around the government
we assume
to
to give education to the kids of these
refugees
on the streets of kogali we found a
sense of hospitality rather than
hostility
we can encourage all of the world to
come to stay in rwanda they may be
called immigrants or whatever they are
just
people
for many who make the perilous journey
for a better life places like this will
now be the ultimate destination
but the debate around whether the
decision is right has only just begun
shingi maraike sky news kigardi